a weekend of religious violence in a
city in the United Kingdom has
highlighted how religious polarization
in India is impacting South Asian
communities abroad we're talking of
Leicester here a beautiful Multicultural
City in the east of England with a
sizable South Asian Community this
comprises people from both India and
Pakistan that is both Hindus and Muslims
over the weekend young men from both
communities attacked each other on the
streets and one of the causes of the
violence can be traced more than 4 000
miles away in India but first here's
what happened tensions began in Earnest
in late August after India defeated
Pakistan in an international cricket
match in Dubai groups of fans ended up
clashing with each other in Leicester
fueled by nationalistic sentiment made
worse by social media disinformation
and last Saturday the city saw a sudden
and unannounced march by young men
through the streets the problem as you
will hear in this video sourced from
Twitter they were chanting religious
slogans that have come to be associated
with India's Hindu right wing
[Music]
now just to be clear what they are
chanting there is hail Lord Rama now Ram
is one of hinduism's most revered Gods
but over the years this chant in his
name has been usurped by right-wing
Hindus as an assertion of a muscular and
aggressive Hindu identity in India
so it didn't take long for a reaction
videos emerged on Twitter of a flag
outside the Hindu temple in the city
being torn down young men from the
Muslim Community also gathered to
protest the unplanned March where Hindu
slogans that you just heard were raised
taken together all of this follows a
familiar template of religious
provocation and response seen in India
in recent years following a majoritarian
brand of Hindu politics by the ruling
BJP
the violence in Leicester was in fact
serious enough for the Indian High
Commission in the UK to issue a strong
condemnation and call for action against
those involved
and action was taken police had arrested
up to 47 people till Monday and also
discovered that some of the perpetrators
had traveled to Leicester from other
cities in England to fuel the violence
it prompted the mayor of Leicester sir
Peter solsby to say the following to the
Guardian newspaper
I could I have talked to many people
across the community since this trouble
began and they are utterly baffled by
this it does not represent anything that
is simmering in Leicester and does seem
to have more to do with subcontinental
politics
so is all this all really connected
let's get more from Ashok swear and
professor of peace and conflict research
at uppsala University in Sweden
Professor Swain is the violence in
Leicester connected to the right-wing
majoritarian politics we're seeing in
India right now
you see the Leicester is a city which
has been living uh I mean the Hindus and
Muslims uh there have been a large
number of immigrants coming from India
as well as Pakistan and other countries
but the Hindus and Muslims living
amicably in that City for a long period
of time what we see in the since last
month there has been a regular violence
taking place and it started with a match
India Pakistan played and after that
there was this kind of usual after match
the sports fan do the procession but
then it turned the India Pakistan to
Hindu Muslims and this kind of uh
violence which has been continuing now
and also getting people from the other
parts of the city so to coming there
what we see the difference is that the
there is the large the for the first
time we saw that is this Hindu groups or
in the right-wing groups are also or the
language which is being used in this
violence the Hindu writing groups are
language which was used in or which are
continues to be used in India now and so
so the kind of things which you are
looking at it in the other parts of the
world where the diaspora has gone
particularly we saw in Australia the
kind of content going on between the
Hindu diaspora and other diaspora like
Muslims and Sikhs in us it's a similar
type of thing but those are very
sporadic incidents but here it's now for
uh more than a month this is going on
and that's quite looks like a much more
faster it has come that kind of
incidence coming from Indian side the
Hindu Muslim kind of rivalry to now as
arrived in in the Europe you're someone
who looks at right-wing politics in
India quite closely why is this imp
impacting Indian origin communities
thousands of miles away from India
you see that there is a different time
that the migrants have come from India
and the migrants those particularly who
came before they have they used to live
together because there was a no such
difference even between Indian migrants
and Pakistani migrants they were all
being you know living amicably there are
Hindu there was a problem of Hindu and
Muslim migrants who are also not there
but it started gradually started since
92 I think the when the ramzan bhumi
movement which is the against the uh
babri mosque which started in India as
after that I think we see so there is a
the way it started dividing the diaspora
Indian diaspora to the Hindu and Muslim
diaspora groups but I think that was a
kind of very limited skill but there was
not really this kind of violent
reactions against each other what has
happened in recent years there is a
number of of new migrants new students
new way of looking for the jobs and they
have migrated to different parts of the
world particularly in London England and
also in our countries in the developed
countries and with them they bring those
ideas as well they are bringing this a
kind of Hindu right-wing Hindu
supremacist ideas which have uh taken
place in India in a much bigger forceful
way in the last eight nine years they
are bringing with and I think they are
also getting support from those groups
who are in power in India and also the
Indian media so it's a combination of
Indian
regime support Indian media support and
the kind of people we are migrating to
this part of the world we're talking
about more than 17 million Indians and
people of Indian origin who live in
nearly 200 countries how big is their
risk that religious polarization that
one is seeing in India spreads to these
communities
it's a huge risk I think it is it's not
even a risk now it has now
it has gone quite in a big way in
different parts of the world
recently we saw a major controversy in
New Jersey as well like there is a even
the Indian Independence Day parade
parade was going through in a kind of a
bulldozer which is a a
symbol of a operation of Muslims in
India and that really became a bigger
issue we have as I was mentioning these
things have really happening quite often
in Canada in Australia even in con you
know places all over Europe is taking
place quite regularly what is looks like
now because of this situation which is
gaining or particularly the Hindu
right-wing groups that who are gaining
the strength and particularly they are
RSS of RSS and BJP ruling party they do
have their International organizations
have been active and spreading all over
the world and they are also for
recruiting these people and also the you
know the similarly the Muslim youths are
also organized beforehand so I think it
is it's it's a very uh difficult time to
see over and this this is the situation
that we are not real looking forward to
but this is almost uh inevitable now
that there will be more and more classes
between Hindus and Muslim diasporas of
South Asia but saying that I also think
it is harming Indian interest not only
Indian government's interest also the
people who are the Indian diaspora's
interest in general
we'll have to leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us today Professor Ashok Swain
from uppsala University in Sweden
it's my pleasure